[Musique]
voilà donc bienvenu bienvenu ce soir
pour la finale dans ce grand prix des
chèques de bordeaux 2007
[Applaudissements]
merci donc pour cette finale totalement
inattendue puisque ce sont deux
outsideurs qui sont arrivés autour de
cette finale nous allons donc suivre ce
spectacle avec grande attention je vais
faire un petit rappel pour ceux qui
viendraient uniquement pour voir pour la
finale pour le principe de ce grand défi
du bureau qui la préparent découvrir le
jeu d'échecs dont écrans géants ici qui
permet de suivre l'échiquier en direct
ici sur cet écran et vous avez aussi des
cases que vous dans laquelle vous pouvez
écouter les commentaires qui seront
données par le président
l'échiquier bordelais renault lagune et
moi même vous aurez aussi donc
la possibilité de suivre le temps alloué
à chaque joueur
si on va donc se sont départis de 20
minutes par joueur donc une fois avec
des gants une fois avec les noirs donc
c'est un match entre deux parties en cas
d'égalité au bout des deux parties de 20
minutes par joueur
il y aura alors des blitz de départage
se sont départis de cinq minutes par
joueur de blitz et en cas d'égalité en
fait un bout de ces deux blitz un
dernier blitz de cinq minutes pour les
blancs et quatre minutes pour les noirs
avec obligation aux blancs de gagny
voilà le petit avantage autant pour les
blancs mais là nul suffit au noir pour
être déclaré vainqueur voilà le principe
des matchs et de ce grand prix voilà
alors on va passer tout de suite à cette
finale sans plus attendre donc
le premier d'entre eux est bien il est
bordelais c'est le premier maître
international bordelais de l'histoire
d'un couple aux deux premiers formé à
bordeaux
pur produit local
il est champion de france junior et l'ol
il a éliminé olivier rhône et donc lors
de son match de quart de finale grand
maître international est en demi finale
il a tué deuxième surprise puisqu'il a
éliminé est bien le favori de l'épreuve
laurent frayssinet lui-même donc membre
de l'équipe de france numéro 4 français
50e joueur mondial
j'en passe et des meilleurs donc
vraiment grand favori de ce tournoi qui
s'est fait donc éliminés par ce jeune
joueur au tempérament de feu vous
applaudir bien fort le maître
international mathieu cornette de
mathieu corner
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en renfort mathieu donc qu'il est
inattendu
[Musique]
encourager le courage et l'eau parce que
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est que c'est un moment vraiment
important une finale de grand prix comme
celui ci alors face à lui il est encore
plus jeune puisqu'il a à peine 16 ans il
est champion d'europe cadet il a été
évidemment champion de france avant
cadets aussi il est déjà maître
international donc à peine 16 ans on l'a
dit alors il a fait un parcours aussi
remarquable puisqu'il a éliminé le
deuxième favori de l'épreuve le
finaliste 2005 face aux grands karpov
qui avait poussé karpov au départage à
l'époque
hicham hamdouchi ça c'était dans son
quart de finale d'hier et en demi finale
il a disposé du grand maître aussi
alberto david qui est quand même un très
très grand joueur deux fois vainqueur du
championnat de paris un des plus grands
tournois du monde tourne en open
donc il dit tout jeune 16 ans donc c'est
tout à fait exceptionnel le voir aussi
en finale de ce grand prix qui va
succéder quand même un palmarès
exceptionnel ici s'ils gagnent aussi
mathieu s'il gagne l'un des deux donc je
vous demande d'applaudir bien fort de
supporter la peine 16 ans est le maître
international romain edouard medouar
[Applaudissements]
beaufort romain donc motivé pour cette
finale un peu de pression ou le fait de
jouer contre un joueur comme mathieu que
tu connais peut-être déjà d'accord donc
pas de problème particulier relaxe il
est déjà effectivement il a déjà réussi
son tournoi en étant en finale et ça va
sûrement être une très très belle finale
pour arbitrer ce match je vous demande
d'applaudir l' arbitre international
patrick besse fabrication merci stéphane
nous allons tirer au sort
la couleur pour débuter le match
alors messieurs il veut tenter sa chance
bon alors on ne recensait
[Musique]
vous
bon mathieu a remporté le temps s'il va
débuter la partie à première partie avec
des noix des jours avec les blindes pour
l'abonné botha voilà donc si vous
entendez lever la main voilà vous êtes
avec nous pour suivre cette grande
finale donc on va se caler évidemment
tout de suite donc qu'elle voulait cette
petite opération cromer edouard face à
un mathieu koné dont mathieu qu'on est à
choisi les noyers domaines traditionnels
entre les deux adversaires
c'est parti donc eu quatre des six
centres acquis petit centre oui ça c'est
une défense moderne
une défense qui va peut être évoluer
vers une défense philidor différé avait
que 5 avec cinq ces six cavaliers b17
c'est un ordre de coûts particulier pour
jouer la fille leader voilà ça s'appelle
la défense philidor de ce début de
partie un euro non oui avec le pion aux
cinq défendue par le pion des six et
puis le pion ces six là même un nom
cette cette variante là
le coût à 5 d'être jouée par les noirs
parce qu'il y avait eu à 4 contrôler le
pays bas 4 5 rbds et 4 qu'un petit piège
pièce je connais qui a sacrifié en
j'étais en train de voir de quel piège
eux tu parlais message est oui j'ai
compris ici ensuite on via les
lecavalier et ensuite on vient on bien
attaquer la dame mais s'il vient ici on
a cinq
c'est un piège oui c'est un piège c'est
pas le coi 4 amène un petit piège c'est
compliqué oui c'est un truc que mathieu
connaît comme un corps regarder quand il
était jeune mais oui messieurs pour
jouer la contre 1 contre l'as philidor
donc comme une conne et nuit et qu'il
allait noir il a joué à cinq pour ne pas
tomber dans ce piège donc alors ici les
ouvertures au centre vers tir au sol ses
classiques et mathieu a beaucoup étudié
la la fille leader qu'il pratique depuis
quelques années donc c'est une défense
qu'il connaît vraiment très bien
donc là le cavalier attaque le fou sans
doute il vaut là il va reculer le fond
si l'on remet enfin profite du fait que
la tour là l'idée taurin c'était pour
toi peut rapatrier le fonds a pas trier
le folk soit la case d'insécurité on
laisse pas évident prendre le fouet et
reprendre du pied qui serait un désastre
voilà alors le coup dessin tout de suite
des singles contre coup normal de
libération des centrales dont contre on
va rappeler renault envers ceux qui
viennent découvrir la finale ici le
centre donc très important de jouer pour
le centre donc là où vous voyez que les
joueurs connaissent bien évidemment ce
sont des très bons joueurs même s'ils
sont jeunes
ils sont tous les deux maîtres
internationaux ont déjà joué dans ce
tournoi de très très haut niveau et donc
ils jouent pour le centre voilà des 5 et
les blancs auraient pu choisir de
prendre des seuils mais ils choisissent
plutôt la pousse et c'est ce qui est
plutôt favorable à la taxe vers le roi
noir là l'idée de du coût 1,5 chaque
fois que quand tu peux jouer eux 5
contre le coût des 5
ça permettra plus tard de jouer le pion
f4 pour un faire un duo de pions le
fameux duo d'attaqué 4 f5 et f4 f5 7 6 7
6 pouces et aussi si c'est le cas elle
fait ensuite il l'a fait d'ailleurs la
très bien sûr il joue le thème normal se
servant du duo d'attaqué tous se sentent
de vos joueurs tactique de tacticienne
défendre attaquer ce que jean que ça va
être le reflet très active
quand je voi alors mathieu prendre des
précautions g6 pour pour pas donné tout
de suite je me soucie avec mais fléchit
ce qui se passe je sais pas voilà et
celle là non j'essaie de d'enlever ma
flèche et en deuxième voire la première
peut être la deuxième en titre celle là
je me soucie voit la fin voilà je suis
arrivé j'ai 6 voilà c'était bien sûr le
à new york policiers qui le policier qui
doit relancer
et inquiète et ibra s'envolant dit on
n'avait pas vu les flèches et le gars
lui répond en titubant
j'avais pas vu les indiens cavaliers
vous n'y auriez 7 c'est une sorte de
cavaliers enfin kito à d'habitude c'est
le fou qu'on mais là non
oui donc ils contrôlent ici ces cases
notamment les cases et 5 e 6 1 plus que
la case h5 qui servent pas à grand chose
ces cases la voilà il veut les cheveux
il veut freiner la poussée rené ses
pions f5
voilà ses pions pour l'instant les pions
aussi f7 g6 et le fou ces huit contrôle
bien la diagonale à et bizarrement c'est
un cavalier qui est ancien ghetto dit
pas oui généraux mais il est sûr le
petit flanc sur le film ghetto mais il a
son rôle défensif c'est un cavalier
défensif au dernier coup de maître
cornette fugate
alors quelle peut être la signification
de ce coup alors le cavalier est clouée
sur l'atome voilà qui cherche et cherche
des cas s'activent pour penser pièce oui
donc faux b4 ce qu'ils voudraient
peut-être songer vous contre ce cavalier
pas tout de suite ce serait plutôt
pénible ça serait puni puisque le full
deviendrait très puissant très fort
selon des vols le pion 6 ne demande qu'à
avancer le pion aux singles 24 ans erna
6 pour libérer la diagonale noir alors
position encore au complexe 1 puisque
bon le problème c'est cette mauvaise
case cette mauvaise pièce cavaliers mais
si cela qui
il n'a pas de bonnes cases pour
l'instant auquel on revient seul puni le
placer changé mais la position n'est pas
bloqué ça reste une position ouverte
il n'y a pas de deux béliers de pions
c'est-à-dire de pions qui se bloquent
les uns les autres sauf sur l'ale dame
le pion à 4,6 option en bélier avec le
pion à 5 à l'embellie s'appelle la
structure bélier voilà quand les deux
pions fonds sont face à face
bien sûr comme de bélier sur le prêt est
noir on joue ici l'idée s'il vient de
contrôler cette poussée un peu plus
difficilement poussée avec les blancs
oui oui mais il a joué ouachin parce que
s'il veut jouer 5 il faut qu'il joue
g400 qui le prépare ça oui il a joué
ouachin peut-être pour un jour jouer g4
et jouer f5
mais comment le roi serait derrière son
pion la colonne gc les joueurs d'
attaque n'a pas peur d'aller de l'avant
et jouer le plan de structures c'est à
dire j'ai 4 puis f5 alors qu'elles
eurent la signification en os ou qu'on
mystérieux cavalière 3 le coup il revenu
sur la case f3 qu'est-ce qui voudrait
faire un cavalier f3 il a exclu tout est
lisse et il se fait plus et oui alors de
clouage l'île du cadrage ici le cavalier
est clouée sur le fou ce cavalier est
cloué ici ouais sur le fou par le fou et
devant la dame donc le coût cavalière 3
c'était éventuellement pour aller en d4
la case pivot de passage pour pour peser
sur la poussée f5 accompagner la poussée
f5
c'est pousser la wii est toujours kéké
et le thème on veut le réaliser si on
peut pour pour attaquer le petit rock le
petit robe noire donc des coûts d'attac
thématiques et les défenses par clouage
qui s active
de clouage boom est bon alors voilà déjà
il pose la question déjà tout de suite
romain edouard qu'est ce que tu fais
avec ton fouet maintenant si tu viens
sur la case h5 pour garder le clouage tu
perds le faut tu perds le fou parce que
j'ai 4 ans ferme le fourrage 5 qui
n'aurait plus de cases et qu'ils seront
obligés de s'échanger contre le pion g46
risperdal ps ce qui serait pas très
heureux effectivement donc le fou doit
partir c'est changer alors soit
effectivement le fond recul je ne sais
pas où mais on a aussi pas intérêt à
donner une paire de fou ah ouais mais
bon est-ce qu'il a le choix
lorsque la position n'est pas déterminée
c'est à dire lorsque les pions sans
mobile mais sutout ce qui moi ça
m'embête vraiment ce coup que jouer
maître cornette parce que
c'est souvent tout s'échange ils
contrôlent moins bien les cases blanches
en mai va garder s'en fout je pense il
est venu provoquer le pion à 3 pour que
le roi se dégarnissent un petit peu pour
ouvrir le bal à et des accès il aime
bien attaquer des rois mal protégés
mathieu ils organisent ces pièces
contraire c'est un bon joueur d'attac
donc c'est un coup pour provoquer je
crois qu'il pourrait jouer voilà il
revient également fois donc en fait
c'est une provocation convocation à la
rocky h3 donc provoquer les
affaiblissements autour du roi
voilà pourquoi pas mais d'un autre côté
ça peut aider les blancs très attention
parce que le pion des mobiles
donc oui donc si la diagonale blanche
s'affaiblit le fouquet thanassis
récupère la diagonale blanche pour
montrer mon frère y est on va jouer sur
joue g4 on affaiblit cette grande
diagonale ici et ça peut avoir des
cancers rejoint échec ici il peut y
avoir en jouant le coût des cas d'écart
voir au bon moment mais pas n'importe
comment on récupère les diagonales le
fou en d5 aura une très belle diagonale
vers le roi donc ce serait sans doute
une erreur stratégique indo j4 ne pas
avancer les pions devant son roi de
façon inconsidérée
ça peut être des moutures en attaque
mais ils vont bien en général bien que
le centre soit fermée à la fin sur un
passé dégarnir trop vite
voilà sinon le risque est trop grand ou
alors on est sûr d'avoir une position
d'attaqué qui alors petit qui paye est
petite combine est si les noirs jeu des
quatre qui a l'air bien puisque sur
cavale et prend évidemment dame prend et
si lecavalier bouge bien on récupère la
tour derrière mais ça ne marche pas tout
simplement parce que sur des 4 c'est
tout simplement le petit coup tour des
uns et les noirs ne peuvent pas prendre
le cavalier puisque la tour prendrait la
dame donc une
une menace plutôt artisanale un cavalier
h5 voilà ce cavalier g3 alors fourchette
le style direct primaire mais hop échec
au moins on en profite pour attaquer à
la fois là est assez g3 et le pian f4 et
la dame g2 la dame de est perdu donc
c'est bien de jouer il faut inventer ça
il faut aimer sa part et c'est là qu'on
voit l'intérêt d'avoir provoqués je
crois bien sûr je crois a affaibli la
classe g iii mais attention il ya un
souci une fois défendre f4 et oui on
défendre si sa convalescence et ça mais
il faut jouer c'est pourquoi la dame 3 1
mais 2 3 1 3 2 3 il va se heurter à
lecavalier qui défendent et quatre à des
menaces il ya cavaliers prendre mais il
peut ya voir si ces cinq là c'est une
position que mathieu affectionne un
élève la position où je n'aime pas trop
la position de ronin le coup h3 était un
coût et ce coût à 3 la mine de rien oui
mais petit affaiblissement et et le cas
validé son heure oui si angers certes la
firme kétou voilà qu'il était prêt prêt
à bondir et rebondir
attention problème pour romain edward
lin alors ça serait quand extraordinaire
si mathieu cornette gagne la dame à 3 et
force et son pote à perdre le client f4
gagner évidemment son premier grand prix
de bordeaux devant son public
pourquoi pas il va falloir quand même
voilà ces cinq avec la menace en score
c'est ce que je signale est toujours là
mais c'est ce direct la menace d 4d 4 le
style direct
il n'y a pas donné pas de solution que
peuvent faire les blancs il faut pas il
faut pas perdre le cavalier donc qu'il
faut clouer peut-être le pian des cinq
peut-être jugé qu'à peut-être peut-être
joué g4
et sur des quatre dans ce cas là oui
mettez vos pièces sur des cases active
et les échecs se chargeront du reste
n'en saura pas de calais les
combinaisons arrivants problemo problema
et chouchou problème alors une solution
peut-être renoncer même si j'aime pas
beaucoup ces deux autour des 1 pour
éviter la voilà ce qu'en disait cloud
est le pire des 5 et sur des quatre jeux
des clous et le cavalier à serra
n'obtient pour garder et du curé car
voilà et bien sûr des quatre est un coût
qui ne doit pas être joué à la légère
puisque il livre la case de 4 qui
conduit à la case f6 pour pour les
cavaliers
ça permet d'aller et ensuite plus tard
quand on aura enlevé ce cavalier d'ici
peut-être oui la faire un échec de
johnny 4 et puis le cavalier est un
cavalier en 6e dangereux change
d'appellation attention et devient ce
qu'on appelle un dinosaure façade va
m'aimer les noirs peuvent très bien
jouer des quatre quand même un là tout
de suite là il faut réfléchir évidemment
oui oui jours il est blanc attention bas
il sortirait saddam mais où peut-être
ans
c'est ce que tu disais oui y'a pas toi
y'a pas le jouer comme ça mais bon on
défend f4 et on a récupéré la case
d'accord elle est pas belle enseigne la
dame un ipad elle elle est pas belle
c'est plutôt passif c'est lui plus tôt
mais après 25
elle obtient la casaque 6 attention et
si on l cavaillé 1,4 c'est à dire des
menaces la dame ici pour y venir en a
six et après cavaliers g5 cema
évidemment h sept cavaliers g5 ou
d'allégements 4 et 6 attention ne pas
s'affaiblir en attention aux coups de
pions attention attention de quoi
déboussoler oubliant affaibli des cases
et donc il faut les jouer vraiment avec
lucidité c'est à dire être conscient
tout à fait de la case
quand livres alors que l'avancé de pion
à l'arc ou pour les noirs possible avoir
corrigé trois cavaliers j'ai très cher
venir peut-être 4,5 pour regagner un
thème pourtant lada bien sûr bien sûr et
peut-être aussi gagné la paire de fou
simplement jouer cavalier prend f1 et
ensuite le fou le kazoo la hanche va
être puissant prendre ce fou et ensuite
se fout là se fout là une fois liens
dans le pied en d4 sera joué même s'il y
aura la case 4 1
on pourra venir en masse à l'action et
il ya plus de défenseurs de cases
blanches aura ghm pas trop moi ce genre
de coups parce que moi j'ai ans mais sur
une diagonale ici pénible dès que les
noirs jouent le coup c 4 il suffit de
jouer par exemple pour ses 8 et la
menace pouces et 5
donc il a échoué d'où la dame sur le roi
joue des quatre quand même
oh la la les noirs sont très actifs ah
oui des tables km oui je pense qu'une
des idées et vous la danse et c'est de
jouer fou princes et rois puis vous
prend ici oui puis ensuite de jouer
peut-être la prise de la dame pour
changer contre l'autre dame et de jouer
eux deux qui enferme le fou est faible
défendu par le cavalier j'ai trois noms
mais la wii comme si un match oui oui il
va jouer dames c'est un sac de jouer
autre chose
peut jouer aussi dans damme 6e non il va
pas il va pas remettre ça demain eu un
enclos h avec le fou surtout pas quoique
peut attaquer le cavalier ici mais où
irait la dame ensuite attention parce
que lecavalier mais le cavalier va venir
en f 5 et en os 3 renom mais oui telle
qu'elle est mais le gaz mais bien sûr on
l'appelle case mais les blancs se font
déborder par les noirs ils se font
prendre toutes leurs cases cette case
est très faible
on y réfléchit on voit bien que le
cavaliere est léchée videmment cavaliers
au 4 mai cavaliers 4 il ya les charges
du cavalier puis food et 5 et le fou est
très puissant qui est le cas de la clio
iv ici le blanc joue cavalier 4
absolument de jouer c'est au nord donc
la police blanc n'ont pas eu peur
c'est d'ailleurs aux cibles je suis même
pas si énorme peut pas jouer tu en
france et 3 qu'est-ce qui se passe qui
en france est roi ouais non ça marche
pas ça prendra mais s'ils ont mis à prix
à tour prend un échec
j'étais en train de me dire qu'on peut
ramasser une pièce deux pièces et que
derrière il ya une tour d'attaquer mais
non voyez donc qu'il faut ça il faut
sortir cela laisse à calar suffisant
cavalière 5 et est bien une très très
belle 15 en trois ans la dame va sortir
du vis-à-vis de la tour oui et ensuite
le cas où il va pouvoir venir en trois
ans entre le mans et le four récupérer
la grande diagonale et se fout ici
récupérer la grande diagonale à 8 g h1
très grande diagonale roi des belles
pièces mais gros semble-t-il grosse
initiative du côté noir peut-être même
davantage
mais c'est sûr avantage quoi s'est pas
fait c'est certain et avant moi je
m'étonnais attention il ya aussi des
troupes d'écouté noir donc il va falloir
faire très attention ne pas s'emballer
parce que si les noirs prennent la case
f5 et la case 3 les blancs pourront
peut-être prendre la case de 4 et
ensuite la case m6 avec aussi des
possibilités d'attaqués sur le roi donc
c'est pour ça que tu proposes est
frustrant cavaliers oui sans doute mais
oui vous prend cavaliers pour éviter
tous pour éviter ce souci à leur belle
finale a en tout cas là ça ça ça attaque
d'emblée
tout de suite je suis pas sûr que romain
edouard son comptable sa position quand
même il prend du temps comme il a dit
romain edouard il est déjà très content
d'être en finale c'est rien du tout eh
oui donc il a quand même battu richard
landucci finaliste en 2005 face à karpov
il a battu alberto david gagné deux fois
le championnat de paris on n'est plus
dans open du monde
c'est une peine qui a réuni des x 800
900 mille joueurs
le championnat de paris dont dizaine de
grands maîtres à chaque fois
vertou david et bien il s'est fait
proprement sortir par ce petit jeune de
16 ans qui fait beaucoup parler de lui
cette saison champion d'europe c'est
quand même pas rien champion d'europe 1
depuis cessé on attendait peut-être un
titre important international depuis
depuis l'été une bague gros voiliers de
l'est les champions du monde des moins
de 10 ans les moins de 12 ans aussi oui
puis maintenant est classé 18e joueur
mondial etienne bacrot notre numéro un
français qui a déjà été classée 8e
mondial la saison dernière qui a un peu
chuté là mais il est encore très jeune
indienne manqueront donc là sans doute
se refaire une santé il a d'après
d'expérience on va dire donc là il
hésite il hésite à apprendre c'est fou
f1 avec lecavalier
alors non il veut pas - le four n'ose
vous ce four n'a aucune importance
il veut prendre la case ou 3 ou à jouer
tout de suite quand même à 9,53 il va
attaquer la tour il va il va poser des
gros soucis ou blancs qui sont quand
même très très coincé là dans l'or dans
leur camp mais c'est vrai que les noirs
aussi ont des trous un essai de gaz et
fils est très faible donc il faudra
peut-être faire [ __ ] enclave alliés
oui puis non mais l'a pour l'instant
tant que la dame est là le cavalier ne
doit pas bouger puisque sinon c'est la
dame qui est perdu au pardon bailly pas
comme ça évidemment mais comme ceux ci à
l'oeuf ou cloud lecavalier voilà ça
s'appelle un clouage si la pièce bouge
c'est la grosse pièce derrière qui perd
nous et sachant que cette pièce peut
être exploité par le coup cavaillé des
cinq ce clonage peut être exploité par
le coup comme il s inquiète aussi avec
baignoire jacuzzi girl et des sacs bien
sûr l'attaqué trois fois bien sûr bien
sûr attaqué trois fois ça c'est vraiment
un vingtième 6 1
peut-être même que les noirs peuvent
jouer tout de suite cavaliers il est en
baisse le cavalier regarde voilà peine
de regarder ça qu'elle décès on laisse
le câble et j3 donc d'hawaï en g3 et on
prend ces trois par exemple du pion et
on tue complètement ce fou mais le
foulée 4 est mort aussi et surtout on
prendrait du cavalier ça prendrait du
cavalier fou prend vous prend
et on aurait là la paire de faux donc
cavaliere alors là c'est la dernière
option ou heroes cible revenir à la
table attaqué le pion un certain culte y
ont attaqué le pion aux réformes c'est
terrible ce qui lui fait la dernière
option de ceux de ce cavalier mais omis
profite à fond de cette de cet
affaiblissement h3
oui la case f4 qui est toujours en
liaison avec avec la vraie
alors est ce que les blancs pour y jouer
j'ai trois voix des conseillers
ah oui bien sûr ça fait oublier un peu h
3 mai à troyes est défendu par le
nouveau nom il laisse tomber m
il relève le clouage et j'en ai ras le
bol je laisse tomber ce pion ça y est
les enlève le clown il lâche le pion
alors à noter que les noirs peuvent
toujours pas prendre ici puisque la tour
prendrait la dame d81 tout simplement
toujours clouage beaucoup de clouage
dans cette partie là il prend voilà il
le prend pourquoi parce qu'on avait dit
ce qu'avait sinon auraient bondi sur
quatre est attaqué et si ce qu'il faut
reprendre le fou voilà et maintenant ils
prendre parce qu'à la barre il tenir le
tempo sur le fou en l'air en c3 en
jouant cavalier des cinq noms qui prend
le pion impunément
je prends le pion puisqu'il va pouvoir
ont maintenant on peut dire combien de
noirs peut souffler un peu c'est à lui
de jouer mais oui mais des jouets avec
un pion de moins sur nos moyens et
surtout un beau toujours un trou énorme
trou énorme et le cavalier b6 peut venir
en dessin qui s'y est attaqué la loi ou
et des formes va falloir elle y est sans
doute que ce fou vient nombre des deux
noms la yam pied auquel toucher un peu
le pour écoper pour boucher les trous et
un client qui est tombé et un gros pions
qui est tombé avec avantage noir grosse
avantage noir donc battu corps net qui
prend l'ascendant dans cette finale avec
les noirs ce qui serait un gros avantage
ainsi mathieu cornette arrive à gagner
avec les noirs et bien ça va être très
très dur pour romain edouard de revenir
et c'est une option pour la victoire
combattu cornette qui pour la première
participation
sa première participation au grand prix
de bordeaux est bien l'emporterait avec
pourtant un plateau extrêmement relevé
voyez alors là c'est bien de voir les
petits circuits tranquille pour le pôle
pour les cavaliers d'avec les les pièces
les pions qui qui qui sont trouvé un
petit peu et qui donne des cases le
petit circuit dé 5,3 la voilà de bien
beau cavalier en tout cas alors juste
pour ceux qui se poseraient la question
ici les termes ici son anglais donc il
faut pas en tenir compte
q c'est pour queen pour la dame baisser
pour bishop le fou les haines pour
knight le cavalier qui en anglais se dit
knight qui veut dire chevallier à bishop
et ans l'évêque le fou se dit évêques en
anglais et donc la dame c'est la reine
évidemment différent alors qu'en russie
en russie le sait pas la dame mais c'est
le premier ministre oui mais le général
de l'armée camp arabe je crois que c'est
le vizir l'ancien vizir
donc celui qui veut devenir calife à la
place du calife calif donc il a perdu un
pion romaine loir et il reste avec des
trous mais bon heureusement pour lui le
fou de cases noires advert cela a
disparu
sinon ça serait un désastre on voit bien
que toutes les cases noires sont
extrêmement floues la bravo toujours
sacrifié leurs adversaires les
ressources toujours à l'affût cavaliers
prendre des quatre super abord cavaliers
proche puisque mais hier on peut prendre
le pion puisque si les noirs prennent
cavalière 4 été pris d'alger 5me plus
fort que cavaler proches croient tout de
suite
ah bon et oui puisque cavaliers pour
naze rage 3 gagne menace la dame oui en
plus à des clous oui on peut prendre on
peut prendre six sur quoi le pion f
prend et la tour est très puissante
ah oui la tour devient extrêmement
puissante après sur la dame
oui oui alors là le contrecoup les
sacrifices a dû le prévoir en cavalier
président avait alors les noirs peuvent
faire cavaler prend échec on peut pas
prendre du plomb puisque la dame c'est
l'idée cloud ici sur le roi et quand le
roi bout je comprends la dame f 2 mai
mais le fait qu'on ait fait cavalier s'y
sont fait qu'on attaque aussi la dame
adverse dans klein je fais quand même le
fait de forcer un puisque ce roi h1 on
aurait pris dès maintenant il prend le
cavalier avec tempo avec échec et prend
le cavalier avec tempo puisqu'il attaque
la dame
ah oui il va prenant leurs alliés il
attaque et il attaque avec mais c'est
pas grave il récupère la case étroite
oui mais récupère à la caisse pour son
cavalier
d'accord mais mais ce que rob edwards a
paru cetoula toujours autour de moi
toujours bien toujours un point de plus
pour les noirs mais mais attention le
pion à 5 est faible pour l'instant
le mobilise un peu la tour à la défense
oui mais le cavalier obtient une belle
case un des cinq qui compenserait même
quasi civils et changent bien gros
avantage noir guerre de cinq cavaliers
vivant et le cavalier centrale n
délogeables compense la paire de fou ce
cavalier loge alors nous puisqu'on
pourra jouer c4i il va il faudrait
qu'ils vouent ses 4 mais attention on
affaiblira la case des quatre là pour
l'instant il va sortir son cavalier la
paire de fou quand même un fait qui va
jouer cavalier des cinq tout de suite
puisqu'il attaque le fou une paire de
fois que le flottant dans le canal est
attaquée redon et jeu long mais surtout
le goût d'après ce sera au tour des six
mais il doit regarder non là il faut
sortir le cavalier où il faut jouer
cavalier qui est dressé un bilan un g5
et oui la case
ils menacent cavaliers ou 4 fourchette
au nom oui petite fourchette alors la
médicine non ça n'arrête pas c'est une
partie de ta this year c'est quasiment
que de la tactique partie de take this
year c'est terrible cela donc la paire
de fou contre la paire de cavaliers mais
un pion pour la perdre la menace on la
voit cavaliers 4 est ici la fameuse
fourchette une dent de dans la
fourchette est pas de manche en fait
cette fourchette le mans je voudrais
être là en fait c'est ça oui voilà
demain c'est le voile a coûté 3 avec le
fou comme ça qui contrôle la case et 5
et après calais des cinq qui attaque et
le fou tout de suite romain à jouer
peut-être qu'après cavaliers olalala le
pion est attaqué c'est horrible à la
faiblesse ou cinq là oui mais la dic
ainsi leur la toile et voilà b6 voilà je
sais ce que je voulais dire
effectivement b 6 semaines en protège
ses cinq protège surtout à cinq qui est
donc libère la tour et donc ça libère la
tour qui va pouvoir venir au centre
si on l'avait joué plutôt évident le
pion à 5 aurait été en prise donc ça
c'est un coup pour libérer la défense
entre en juin il faut qu il
donc là avantage il ya un bec la paire
de fous de jouer il ya égalité et donc
il faut qu'il maintienne absolument ce
bélier z tokyo contre 5,6 les deux pions
pas facile hein pas facile faut qu'il
est d'accord il va essayer d'échanger
une tour sais pas si la position est
favorable à perdre au faou d'antan qui a
le bélier 5,6 là la paire de foule voilà
tu as peut-être à s'exprimer oui la
terre de foule peut pas s'exprimer
donc il faudrait ici est chargé une
pièce lourde et que l'année cavaliers
s'échange contre le défaut donc cette
paire de fous ne peut pas s'exprimer à
plein parce que la pulsion n'est pas
très ouverte à cause de ses deux pions
là qui bloque un peu les diagonales
notamment les diagonales vers le roi
noir
on voit bien que c'est pas facile
d'attaquer le roi noir sinon je sais 4
un jour ou l'autre pour déloger ce
cavalier
le problème c'est qu'on bouche encore
une diagonale sélection de livres à la
casse des quatre îles qu'on donne cette
case
cette case cavaliers un autre calibre il
joue cavalier 1,7 c 6 des 4 par exemple
valeo cède cavale et c6 et ensuite on
reviendrait sur l'a4 bon et puis il ya
toujours des cases et une fois que le
pion à nuancer 4 on pourra plus chasser
sur le cac ce décathlon pourra plus
jouer ses trois pour chasser le cavalier
pour l'instant le kabyle est ici et ça
bloque les colonnes aussi donc ça bloque
un peu ça sèche la position et c'est
favorable aux cavaliers quand les
pressions bloquer les cavaliers sont
plus forts parce qu'il arrive toujours à
trouver des cases où se pose est donc
les fous cherche des diagonales pour
s'exprimer là voilà ils viennent trouver
une petite diagonale pour embêter la
tour ça donne pas grand chose ça gêne à
peine les noirs
voilà il revient des trois îles propose
nul implicitement romaine loir il s'en
sortirait bien avec une nulle la voilà
je ne veux pas évident voilà cavaliers
un set pour aller à 9,5 à ou suis
peut-être un des cas tout ça il perd lui
aussi qu'il n'a pas prévu ce coup là
tout réussit c'est incroyable comment
protéger le pion aux 6 on peut pas jouer
cavalier seul puisque le fou des deux
prendrait deux cavaliers il n'y a pas de
moyen de protéger ceux qui ont alors le
seul coup des noirs jouable tout de
suite ses cavaliers échecs comme il ya
25 échec puis je vais défendre le pion
oui avec la décence passé ce qu'on peut
pas prendre
voilà il donne le pion mais pour
récupérer le cuir et sert
d'interlocuteur par un court instant que
tu va le prendre avec la tour ab je
donne les tours pour un jeu dont une
tour pour deux pièces oui je reste avait
là on appelle ça la à la qualité soviets
et la qualité soviétique voilà c'est ça
l'expression la qualité soviétique
c'est à dire imaginons la après le coup
comme les c6 qui attaquent cinq élus ont
fait tout reprendre 6 6 cavaliers prend
on prend avec la tour et après qu'elle
les prend tous retrouvera on a pris deux
pièces pour la tour et on a deux fous
contre une tour une tour contre contre
l'autre tour est de fous contre une tour
et ces deux fronts et retour s'appelle
la qualité soviétique soviétique
c'est à dire les russes qui met bien
avoir nom d'un ancien pays sacrifiés une
alors il alors à me la jouer carrément
il fonçait droit et laisse même pas
prendre la qualité soviétique maintenant
parce que pourquoi à mais parce qu'il
avait la figure de tours 8 parce qu'il
va courir cavaliers ce qui l'embêtait je
pense était cavalier des quatre qui pour
jeter les deux tours et qui garent
récupérer la paire de fourchette wiki
récupérer un des deux fous avec une
position qui ne faisait que rendre le
matériel qu'ils avaient en plus il y
avait une fourchette derrière donc
c'était pas bon je me suis un peu
emballé
petit mais c'est beaucoup de bases
tactiques toujours sur toujours entre
ses joueurs mais voilà ça va être que ça
qu'à la menace est mature être
essentiellement tactique maintenant que
le fou empêche la fourchette puisque
c'est tout simplement il prendrait le
cavalier il semble que romain edouard il
va quand même à mettre la pression et là
des chances de s'en tirer
même s'il est moins bien quatre minutes
à l'intention important au niveau du
temps voire d ivresse quatre minutes
quatre minutes aux blancs contre 3
minutes cinq cantons noir très important
on a vu beaucoup de parties dans ce
grand prix se jouer autant oui c'est un
grand prix la corne est très très
particulier c'est le premier grand prix
comme ça en équipe en difficulté mais il
est moins bien entend aussi tendue aussi
revient aux temps difficiles
vingt secondes c'est important de tenir
cavaliers g5 voyage où on écrit un
tableau oui mais il veut changer la tour
ça va libérer
peut-être une chance sur des changes la
tour on va libérer vous voyez les joies
et jouera peut-être cavaliers vii bon
pour se servir de ses pions c'est pierre
melville sam lowry sandero il n'a pas vu
le simple courroie g4 il revient avec 7
c'est un aveu de d'erreurs je crois que
c'est un aveu d'erreurs cette question
pensent aux cavaliers à vii et là ça
hyper le pion alors là je peux dire que
ou la mairie les quatre il récupère la
balle avantage à changer de camp au
roudourou il va prendre le pion v6 pas
un courriel cheikh al-cheikh bien sûr
sur une échelle voilà là ok on l'a la
tour 4
je suis pas par contre si c'est bien ça
tangue alors un petit échec
moi je prend ainsi il faut pas mettre le
roi n'importe où il mélange 3 pour
éviter tous les échecs je sais pas si
tour 4-6 bien échanger les tours
finalement là est ce que cette tour
n'était pas bien derrière le pion aux 6
ça me paraît un peu bizarre ce coup
tours 4 attention le plan b si cette
attaque est aussi maintenant c'est un
tel avantage a complètement changé de
camp en quelques mois oui il n'a pas du
tout la position s'est rééquilibré au
point de vue matériel n'a pas vu le
coutour f6 alors la méthode dans les
blancs ont de vrais gros pions passé
centrale pions 5 avec aulas l'a remis
pearl qui ont aussi sur la salle hyper
un pur envahirait que perles pierres ou
5 mais n'en perd pas il va y avoir six
échecs d'abord tout de suite voilà aussi
ce bref si ces attaques trois fois le
pion ils voient leur bail bonne il va
jouer je vais tout racisme et blanc
petit avantage ça peut encore voilà ils
vivent autour 1,6 effectivement il va
prendre le pion à 5
il va laisser les noirs voilà ah non il
prend le fiancé 2 bien vu car le piper
le pion à c'est maintenant est-ce qu'il
va alors faut pas qu'ils perdent option
c56 perles je sais que c'est foutu parce
que ses deux pions passé lié c'est trop
fort mais il va jouer la finale deux
tours il va essayer d'annuler la série
dernière ça s'est perdu c'est perdu les
deux pions sont haussés gagnant c'est
gagné pour mme edwards il reste 3
minutes contre 2018 c'est gagnant deux
pions passé lié sur l'ale dames c'est
aulas lors retournement de situation
norme est dehors dans cette partie qui
était quand même très mal et voilà ils
jouent en est n'a pas vu ainsi gagnantes
sont inarrêtables
c'est complètement inarrêtable ces
théories qu'on peut arriver à retarder
l'avancé les pieds c'est mécanique
c'est complètement mécanique ya rien à
faire c'est très facile à gagner à la f3
tranquille il suffit de pousser les
pions ça va tout seul
attention parce que la tour et non mais
ça va tout seul il pas très bien placé
là il va jouer tour b 2 1 me veulent se
place derrière la prière est tombé 4
tout de suite donc il faut vous tombez 2
mais la wii est maintenant tout
simplement là il va toujours se mettre
derrière le pion qui sera la traîne tout
simplement voilà échec c'est connu un v6
des six tours et chikhaoui voilà il joue
à cinq places à liège ou l'autre pions
voilà on peut pas arrêter ses pions
c'est trop fort
il joue à six voies la menace à 7
il faut l'arrêter fort et espions échec
g2
il va venir en géant et en ligne la
vente il ya des échecs
voilà il se met toujours derrière le
pion avancé minutes 33 contre une et
c'est dans la séquence est perdus c'est
perdu voilà cette menace dame
il peut rien faire ça ailleurs b6 voilà
c'est terminé c'est terminé les pions
sont trop forts oui le triomphe de la
paire de faux aller à dame
la paire de fois réussi pour le moment
environ ça a craché son venin
je vous rappelle que pendant les parties
ne regroupe pas parler va faire depuis
déconcentrer les joueurs
merci
[Musique]
qui